oggi stiamo per fare una cosa c'è che
non so cosa stiamo per andare a fare
lorenzo mi ha detto io sono sempre
potere sorprese più biondo è vero e
siccome ero in macchina e devo bere
perché il mes quick tra l'altro dovevo
verde
mi sembrava che la macchina andasse
abbastanza dritta
il problema che ha beccato una buca
mentre stavo bevendo c'è mi sono vestito
bene però il risultato è questo qui che
ne abbiamo un appuntamento importanza
stato un ora a scegliere la maglia non
il suo sbrodolato come i bambini
io ma che schifo fa male che ha promosso
lavoro in mente trovate al lavoro vero
giulia a mister teramo il professor
layton aspetta faccio una foto
allora cosa dici dietro veramente brutta
fa in pastella ancora bene
molti dire qualcosa nel frattempo grazie
a voi non avete registrato anche ieri
sino a bastava degrado che ai ragazzi
non so se ve l'ho detto ma stiamo
andando gli studios di google però
questo è il vostro boss di bosto zio per
niente quelli sono gli studi di google
quelli quella casa di lorenzo i fiori
rosa dando agli studi di google per
chiedere a google di ambientarmi
demonetizzazione nelle pubblicità perché
perché perché è sempre giusto ma tu sei
questo io mi hanno dato questo zaino dai
dal lungo direttamente col simbolo di
youtube aden dentro c'è qualcosa di figo
c'è un sacchetto di google
effettivamente grazie dentro sacchetto
c'è un altro sacchetto wow sempre pronto
ad aiutarti pietro a google hong giorno
ca volevo farla domandate la vita e la
domanda della vita a lamentarci
e si chiamava the camera che non
nasconda qualche parte di smetterla di
fare i vivi
[Musica]
sono tornato a casa ragazzi ho trovato
pietro e tra l'altro in casa mia però
non c'era prima
mi hanno regalato google home che lo
proverò domani perché adesso non c'ho
voglia deve lavare i piatti non sto
scherzando avevo messo messo questo è
perché non ho voglia di pulire le braci
anche un'etichetta di pokémon io un
regalo perde mai fammi vedere dal
giappone oggi i legali non ricevono lo
zaino no lei e nello zaino fermo
fermenti visto qualcosa che gli occhi
allora questo è il regalo e la cosa
fisica che in giapponese viene da dio è
un libro così non ti sposi niente può
essere una compressore 3d home again è
un del nord gelo e il numero è il numero
uno a lato di that not in giappone
ok google suona bohemian rapsody dei
queen non hanno ancora scelto una
piattaforma paesi
[Musica]
[Applauso]
aveva passato non è ok google
sai come mi chiamo ti chiami lorenzo
quanto fa 7 per tre
la risposta è 21 qual è la radice
quadrata di 1.500 radice quadrata di
1.500 corrispondono a circa 38,73 chi è
il presidente degli stati uniti
d'america
il presidente degli stati uniti e donald
trump chi estera e basta secondo
wikipedia sfera e basta ok google saluto
al mio video ho capito salute il mio
bilico ciao amici sondando il blog
questo che sta tendendo già in questo
momento lo sto bloggando mancano sei ore
devo prendere un fottutissimo aereo per
los angeles o la stessa identica
maglietta di quando registrato quei blog
perché uno non mi lavo e due sono pigro
è suddiviso in vista aiutando bloggare
devo montare con il portatile mentre di
là c'è la festa del mio papà perché mio
papà fa 56 56 anni facciamo gli auguri
papà è la festa di tutti
[Applauso]
auguri papà grazie sono le undici e
stiamo facendo festa da tre ore mi sono
assentato un attimo per finire di
montare quindi tranquilli ho festeggiato
vi lascio perché tra sei ore o un aereo
per los angeles mentre voi guardate
questo video sono già in volo e niente
noi ci rivediamo proseguito secondo
contro i 10 nuovi cicli di definizione e
facciamo la chiusura con il calzino
bucato di denise
pollice in su al video beh ragazzi
[Musica]